all right ted thanks new details tonight
on the shooting at a chinatown
restaurant where a worker was shot
nearly a dozen times metro releasing
surveillance video of that suspect and
believe he actually could be tied to
other robberies in the area madison
kimbrough is live with what other
businesses are saying tonight madison
yeah other business owners here in the
chinatown area are reeling after this
tragedy that happened right here at
shanghai taste while metro has not
labeled this as a hate crime
those in the community feel targeted in
fear for their safety
this past year has been really hard
for the asian community i was really
upset to find out that something is this
tragic would happen here monday morning
shooting at the popular chinatown
restaurant shanghai taste is still very
much on the minds of many metro released
new surveillance video of the suspect
who attempted to rob the restaurant and
in doing so shot a waiter multiple times
detectives are also looking into another
burglary in the same area saying the two
could be related jack's son owns a
restaurant a couple doors down he says
he wants to feel safe again hopefully we
could have the management of this plaza
have more security
and probably set up more cameras around
the parking lot according to police the
other nearby burglary went unreported
until now this is often the case within
asian owned businesses seni vinuya
president of the asian chamber of
commerce shares they need to be more
vigilant and really reporting to metro
what's going on and have that
communication dialogue with them a lot
of them have really commented i can't
believe that we actually have a
relationship with law enforcement here
unlike from the country that they were
in
they try to stay away
now i heard from the owner of shanghai
taste and it looks like wang is on his
way to a recovery
he says they underwent surgery again for
the second time today reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now madison
thank you